teachers union is calling on lawmakers
to act now following yesterday's
lockdown and an arrest of a student for
several hours authorities search for a
student who reportedly threatened the
school Joshua peguero looking into this
joining us now live here is Joshua with
more
[Music]
hello Brian and Kirsten we spoke with
school police a few hours ago at the
administrative building right behind me
while they say reports of a gun were
unfounded they wanted to stress that
they take these type of threats
seriously
simply put anytime we get a report or a
rumor of a gun we treat that situation
as if there is a gun until we prove that
there isn't a gun this lets in
hours-long lockdown of Shadow Ridge High
School parents went to the school
demanding answers and some are saying
there was a lack of communication we
were kind of left in the dark don't know
what was going on until you informed us
of what was going on as for what was
going on in the school Lieutenant Brian
Zink says students and staff responded
in a proper way so everybody operated
the way that they should have and we're
very happy with the way the outcome
Marine nicest of the Clark County
Education Association says teachers had
problems with the communication so they
were a little frustrated that parents
immediately got a letter from the school
explaining what was happening but yet
staff did it and they're hearing it from
their students police say the student
was arrested for terroristic threats and
assault a 2019 restorative justice law
will impact how the student is
disciplined two bills recently
introduced in the legislature ab330 and
ab285 would allow for the immediate
removal of a student that's not the case
now ccea supports these bills when it's
an egregious violent act that reaches a
level of such as a school shooting or
some severe act we want to make sure
there's zero tolerance
now to put these violent incidents into
perspective Clark County School police
have issued more than 600 criminal
citations to students from August to mid
February on your screen of the top
schools with the most you have Legacy
High School at 35. Cheyenne at 30
Sunrise Mountain at 26 followed by
Peterson behavioral and several other
schools that you'll see on your screen
reporting live Mr Heron Decatur Joshua
peguero eight news now Joshua thank you
as for Shadow Ridge High School District
data showing school police arrested two
students issued six criminal citations
from August of last year right through
mid-February